first though ahead of all children in
england returning to school tomorrow we
can speak now to the education secretary
gavin williamson thank you so much for
being with us
on the program mr williamson um keen of
course to talk about the return
of pupils to the classrooms but i just
want to start on nhs
pay if i may and the government deciding
to give nurses a pay rise of just one
percent
what is it about the last year that's
made the government feel that nurses
deserve a pay cut in real terms well the
government has
every stage been clear in terms of our
commitment to the nhs this is why
over the last year we've seen an extra
six billion pounds being invested into
the nhs this is why over the next few
years
we're going to be seeing a increase of
close to 34 billion pounds going into
the nhs
and over a million nhs staff they're
going to be
receiving pay increases over and above
that
but also we are facing
difficult economic challenges we're
facing uh
almost three-quarters of a million
people who are unemployed and
we have in the context of that decided
to exempt
the nhs from the public sector pay
freeze which
is the only part of the public sector
that has been exempted from that
at the same time though nurses are
getting a pay rise of 1 i mean inflation
next year is expected to be 1.5
so that works out as a pay cut in real
terms i can't help thinking this has got
a flavor of marcus rashford about it you
know
everyone can see the u-10 coming are you
just being wheeled out to defend a
policy that the government's going to
roll back on
well over the last few years we've seen
record increases in terms of the pay
going to our nurses and our doctors
quite rightly
we are facing them uh we're we're we're
effectively facing a
much more difficult economic time and
economic period we've seen a
shrinking of our economy of 10 but what
uh
this is is part of the process and we've
put this forward
uh to uh for for for nurses and for the
nhs
and uh uh but we are always investing in
our nhs this is why we've had a record
investment this year
and continued record investment in our
national health service over the coming
years
the royal college of nursing is
considering industrial action
would that be responsible well what we
always want to do is work with
all of our partners within the nhs to be
able to
get to the very best possible place
we've seen the nhs do magnificent work
over
the last year we've seen a massive
investment
in terms of our nhs but also in terms of
tackling covid
industrial action specifically would
industrial action be
responsible well no one wants to see
industrial
action i'm certain the royal college of
nursing wouldn't want to see industrial
action
but the government is completely
committed to that investment in pnhs
you've seen that all the way through the
pandemic but you've seen that over the
past 10 years
where you've seen record increases in
the amount of investment and the amount
of money that we've been putting into
the nhs
and that isn't just going to be
continuing over this year but it's going
to be continuing
over uh subsequent years as well
okay at a time when you know you're
talking about the economic challenges
is it a good look when nurses are facing
uh pay restraint for example
that the prime minister is considering
splashing out some money refurbishing
the downing street flat
well what we all recognize is you know
it's a period of uh
real making sure that we have sort of a
right across for
the public sector but we aren't nervous
about in terms of investing in those key
public services such as the nhs
such as schools and investing industrial
makeover as well then
but uh you know i i'm i'm like you uh
sophie probably more interested more
fascinated about making sure children
get back to school tomorrow and
uh i know from my perspective as a as a
dad
that's certainly what i'm wanting to say
and i'm sure what many of your viewers
are wanting to see as well
okay well let's move on to school shall
we do teachers deserve a pay rise
well we've already we saw this uh this
year the largest pay increase for
teachers since 2005 but there is going
to be pay restraint uh there is going to
be a pay freeze for the coming year
but we are continuing to invest in
schools we're continuing to invest in
um you know schools right across the
country making sure some of the lowest
funded schools
get extra increases and this gives
schools for resources
in order to be able to support children
as a return back to school but
uh you know we are facing you know
a tough economic time that's why this
year there will be a pay
uh coming year there will be a pay
freeze uh but for this
year that we're entering into of course
it's teachers are seeing the largest
increase since 2005.
okay now of course as you mentioned
school's going back
tomorrow or people return to the
classrooms and tomorrow
big day for so many pupils and parents
across the country
in secondary schools pupils and staff
will be asked to wear face masks
how is this going to be enforced well
what we saw
in september we asked all children to be
wearing face masks
in communal areas where there are
national restrictions which
increasingly uh covered and ended up
proving the whole of the country
and what we saw during that period
there's an incredibly
large number of pupils that followed the
rules uh they were supported in
following the rules by
uh teachers and members of staff and it
worked very very well
and i think uh pupils recognize the
importance of
doing whatever they can do not just to
protect themselves but to protect their
friends and the whole school community
as well as their families and the wider
community
at the same time it's quite different
though isn't it asking children to wear
face masks
all day in the classroom rather than
just in communal areas and it sounds
from your answer that there's
not really anything that you're doing
other than asking pupils
to do it in primary schools as well and
teachers are just supposed to wear masks
where possible i'm really not sure what
that even means i mean it sounds a
little bit like you're saying this is
too difficult for us to work out
we're just going to leave it to the
teachers you you just sort out
yourselves
not at all what we're doing is we set up
very clear guidance as to
how teachers are best be able to
approach this and it's actually informed
by public health england and their best
advice as to how best to
approach this and reduce transmission
but wearing a face mask is just one
small element
of all the uh all the protections that
we put in place
um you know it's whether it is you know
the distancing whether it's
bubbling whether it's keeping uh year
groups together and smaller groups
together whether it's for staggered
uh you know uh sort of home times and
sort of uh welcoming to school
times and all of these measures go
towards reducing covert and what we saw
between september and christmas
is incredibly successful in reducing the
number of instances in covid in schools
only 0.2 percent of pupils
had confirmed covid during that time so
it goes to show it works
but we're adding these extra layers of
protection not just the mask but also
the testing
really to be able to support schools and
help them but it's not just
one single thing it's many many things
that schools are doing
to be able to protect pupils and protect
staff
of course another way that you could
reduce cover transmission schools would
be through vaccinations and would you
like to see
people under the age of 18 be eligible
for vaccinations
well this has got to be absolutely
informed by this best scientific
medical advice and as you're aware there
currently isn't a vaccine that's
available
for those who are under 16 and only one
available for those under 18.
so we've really got to see the research
of the trials and we've got to
look to the best medical and scientific
advice that will be provided by the jcpi
who have
independent experts who are advising
government on this
uh but when we look at vaccinations i
mean the fact that we're
uh you know rolling this out so
incredibly rapidly the fact that the
number of doses are going to be
available to the
nhs is going to be increasing from 2
million to 4 million a week really goes
to show the transformative progress that
we're making and the fact that this
is what is going to help us unlock uh
the whole of a country
and you know we look to next week um
and i think the whole nation looks next
week with some real excitement
because we're looking towards next week
and it's our first the nation's first
step
out of lockdown the first step towards
this uh
process of recovery and getting everyone
back to
the lives that we had just over a year
ago
you say there's going to be a process of
recovery and there clearly will have to
be
you know pretty substantial process of
recovery to help
children and particularly disadvantaged
children
recover from a year of disrupted
education and you've got a review going
on into seeing how best and pupils can
catch up
one of the things that you've said it's
right to have a discussion about
is shortening that summer holiday
and potentially moving to a five-term
year is that something that you're
seriously considering
well it's a whole range of different
sort of proposals that we're looking at
whether it's a five-term year whether
it's lengthening the school day
but also measures such as enhancing the
support that we give to teachers uh
supporting them in their professional
development making sure
they can be actually the very best of
themselves um it's
looking at different specifically though
specifically on the holidays
is that something that is seriously on
the table it could happen
were we looking at holidays we're
looking at lengthening the school day
we're looking at a whole range of
measures and we've asked
sir kevin collins to leave no stone
unturned
for us we see this as one of those
moments a little bit like the 1944
education reform act that came out of
the second world war
um about how we can be transformative in
terms of
changing and improving the opportunities
for young people but it's got to be
evidence-based
we've got to look as to what is going to
have the biggest positive impact on
children's lives
that's the approach that we're taking
and that's what we're looking
as how we can improve the outcomes for
children
so it sounds like you're thinking about
permanent transformative
in your words change when is that review
going to
be announced when will we know what
you're going to do
well it's a whole series of different
changes the first step of those changes
is
what we announced just be of a week
where we set out our plans for catch up
whether it's the expansion of uh
small groups
into helping children catch up what do
we know what's the time frame of it i
mean could it be in place for you know
this summer holiday
well uh what what we've done is we've
asked sir kevin to
look over a period of 18 months what
we're going to be doing as a department
as a government
is looking at a whole series of options
and changes
but there are going to be you know it's
not just all going to be in one day
when it's all announced there's going to
be a whole series of actions that we are
going to undertake
to improve the life chances to improve
the education of children from the most
disadvantaged backgrounds
but actually all children how can we do
the absolute most for every single one
of them to ensure that they do
so much you know get the very best out
of themselves and get the very best out
of their education
okay um i want to talk now about exams
and you've obviously cancelled
exams as we know it for this year you
said that teachers
can effectively decide on the grades
that the people should get and
they can do this basically however they
want they can use many tests they can
look at old exams they can write their
own tests
they can be done under exam conditions
they can be done under zoom they can be
done at home
they can look at coursework they can
look at class work i mean how on earth
can you expect
exam results to be fair and consistent
in these conditions well sophie
we are we'd always start off on the
basis of the best form of assessment
would be through examination of course
that's the most consistent way of being
able to assess children
but we won't we haven't been in that
position to be able to do that
this year so we've had to look at
alternative models this is why we've set
out a very clear structure
for teachers building scaffolding and
guidance around that so they understand
as to
what grades should be awarded for
individual pupils
making sure and the teachers i speak to
um you know
really are approaching this in the most
professional of manners and ways
recognizing how important it is using
that guidance but then on top of that
there's going to be a
both internal uh inspection and quality
assurance within
the school but additional to that is the
external
quality assurance that will be coming
from the exam boards
this is in the process of randomized
testing
you know in terms of randomized audits
of schools right across the country to
make sure they've been following
uh the guidance and uh the the grades
so they've been awarding our fair
assessment of the course or results will
they be looking at then just to put it
in context
well uh and on top of that if i can just
add uh on top of that
is where there are outliers where
schools are
sort of submitted grades that do not
seem to be consistent with what they've
always been able to achieve in the past
any of those outliers exam exam boards
will able to look at those incredibly
incredibly closely and actually work
with the schools to make sure there is
the right assessment
that's something that is going to be
going right across the country and there
is going to be
um you know that large-scale randomized
sampling
but additional is large scale what is
the
genuinely what is large-scale randomized
sampling how many samples are going to
look at
well we're going to be uh looking
extensively across all school settings
uh whether it's private schools whether
it's states how many
and how many and and it will be many
many thousands that will be sort of
looked at in terms of part of that
process
many many thousands of schools or or
grades or
what across schools exam centers
okay because i mean i guess many would
worry you're putting teachers in a bit
of an impossible
position here you've got randomized
exams you've got internal
assessments but many teachers will know
that there of course will be an
incentive to actually inflate grades to
to er on the side of generosity
and if they don't and their peers do in
other schools or in other classes
then they could be putting their pupils
at a disadvantage for life
well so sophie i i think that our whole
teaching profession
approaches this with the most serious
sort of
professional approach uh and what you
would expect and what you would want
uh of teachers and as teachers go into
this process they're going to be
following the guidelines very very
closely
they're going to be uh looking at what
the exam boards have issued the grade
descriptors of saying this is what
a child is meant to have achieved if
they're to be given an a
a b or c at a level or a
a 9876 um in gcse
so they're going to be looking at that
exceptionally closely there's a whole
process
of internal uh quality assurance that
has to go on within the school
but on top of that that's not the uh
over
uh overlaying all that is that the
quality assurance is going to be there
by the examples looking at where there
is potential malpractice
and making sure they come down on that
and but you know
of course any form of assessment is
never going to be as good as exams
that's why we're so committed
to moving forward with exams if that
would be possible but that's not going
to be feasible this year
and and actually if you've seen the
response uh
you know whether we the consultation we
ran that
was over a hundred thousand people took
part in it
and uh and a response from those
teaching professional teaching
organizations
they recognize that wow this is a
challenge for teachers it is
without a doubt the fairest and the best
approach that we can possibly take in
unusual
circumstances now i'm sure you'd admit
it's been a pretty
difficult year we've had the exam fiasco
the algorithm fiasco of last summer
children went back to school for one day
in january only to be sent
home again then of course according to
the education and
endowment foundation a decade of
progress closing that gap between
privileged pupils and more disadvantaged
potentially
lost do you think you've done a good job
well my focus sophie is always about
trying to deliver very best for children
whether that's for 1.7
billion pound catch-up money that we're
delivering into schools for
the launch of a tutoring program that
supports and targets for children from
the most disadvantaged backgrounds the
fact that we
launch a radical reform of post 16
education
making sure that children are best able
to
succeed in whatever route they go down
and my commitment my absolute commitment
by making sure that children
are back in school at the earliest
opportunity that's what my focus is and
making sure
that children are back in school on
monday
tomorrow and making sure they're in the
position to be able to
enjoy their education and really benefit
from it so that's my focus i'll
leave others to do the commentary okay
i'm just looking at the
cabinet approval ratings the latest
cabinet approval ratings as voted
for by conservative party members now
that
pretty generous lot and liz trust is on
plus 86
richie sunak on plus 74. pretty patel
who
broke the ministerial code is on plus
50. there's only two people
in minus territory there's amanda
milling on minus 4.5
and then there's u on minus 43.6
it's not great is it well sophie my
my focus is on one thing getting our
children back into school tomorrow
making sure that children get the
benefit from education and
i think that's what people right across
the country want to
know that our focus the whole
government's focus is on in terms of
delivering
the education that we want all of our
children to benefit from so
you're very much talking about a you
know westminster story
what i think our nation's parents and
our nation's children want to know
is that they're going back to school
tomorrow they're going to have a benefit
of a world-class education
that's what we're focused on delivering
on have you ever
wondered if you know part of the reason
that you're in the job still is because
you're really acting as a bit of a
firewall for boris johnson
you're soaking up a lot of flack from
the issues in education over the last
year
and protecting the prime minister well
the prime minister and myself
have a shared passion this uh belief
that we can transform education
transform the life chances
of everyone all the way through this
pandemic we have highlighted the
consistent fact that education is our
national priority
the schools would be the last things to
close and the
first things to open and that's what we
said and that's what we're actually
delivering on
so the prime minister myself have that
shared passion that shared commitment
for our schools uh and most importantly
for our children
that is where we're completely and
utterly united on
and um you know as i say it's very much
a shared passion that's what we're
delivering on
that's why we've been putting the extra
investment in terms of catch up
helping children not just those children
from most disadvantaged backgrounds but
children from all backgrounds
best be able to uh get the best out of
their school life
okay and as you say the good news
certainly to see all those people return
to the classroom
from tomorrow gavin williamson thank you
very much for being on the program thank
you thanks for having me